part land hosting washington y nueva
york en eeuu tras los recientes tiroteos
que causaron decenas de muertos miles de
manifestantes marcharon por un mayor
control de las armas de fuego me da la
esperanza de que tal vez se puede hacer
algo es difícil porque ya hemos hecho
esto antes y no hemos visto ningún
cambio pero no significa que vayamos a
dejar de luchar el 24 de mayo un joven
de 18 años asesinó a 19 niños y a dos
profesoras sin una escuela primaria de
ubal de cerca de la frontera con méxico
unos días antes un supremacista blanco
también de 18 años mató a 10 personas
afrodescendientes en búfalo en el
noroeste del país
el presidente de byd él pidió a sus
conciudadanos que se mantuvieran
movilizados
demasiada gente está muriendo
innecesariamente y lo que se propone en
la cámara y en el senado es marginal
pero de todos modos la respuesta es
marcha vaivén también reiteró las
reformas que quiere del congreso como la
prohibición de los fusiles de asalto y
de los cargadores de alta capacidad y el
reforzamiento de los controles de
antecedentes psicológicos de los
compradores pero en un país en el que
casi uno de cada tres adultos posee al
menos un arma los conservadores se
oponen firmemente a cualquier medida que
en su opinión vulnera lo que llaman sus
derechos la cámara de representantes
votó el miércoles 8 de junio la
prohibición de la venta de rifles
semiautomáticos
a menores de 21 años
pero esa medida no tiene casi ninguna
posibilidad de ser aprobada en el senado
donde se necesita el apoyo de 10
conservadores